[Musique]
sa touche vraiment des traitements
extrêmement courants on a vu et je pense
que c'est certainement ce qui a choqué
le plus ça a touché des traitements
d'enfants l'amoxicilline qui est un
antibiotique qui est très très courant
c'est le doliprane ce sont des
médicaments y compris anticancéreux donc
on voit bien là que le spectre est très
large et qui a besoin que le Sénat
travaille sur ces questions
[Musique]
on a besoin de réinstaller des
savoir-faire de prendre en compte de
dans le cycle du médicament qui a besoin
de principes actifs qui a besoin de
d'ingénieur chimiste qui a besoin de
d'industrie de transformation pour avoir
la forme galénique le comprimé faire mes
sombre effervescent etc et puis aussi
d'avoir une autonomie en matière de
contenant c'est-à-dire
les ampoules les blisters une commission
d'enquête l'avantage c'est que les gens
que nous auditionnons prête serment donc
à la fois on va travailler sur le
constat et puis voir aussi quels sont
les pistes pour sortir donc de ces
pandémies c'est le souci de la part des
pouvoirs publics de se dire nous on a
des stocks et s'il y a un pépin on peut
y répondre
[Musique]